et alors que la campagne s'accélère les
petites trahisons entre amis battent
leur plein marine le pen n'est pas la
seule à en faire les frais valérie
pécresse également eu son lot de
défections parmi ses rangs alors la
présidentielle 2022 et elle dominée par
les coups bas c'est l'heure de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler en direct un
livre casanova spécialiste en
communication également en direct eric
revel éditorialistes arte france bonsoir
à tous les deux sur ce plateau à
boulogne et non pas erik reumann direct
pierre frais légumes rlr de dreux
bonsoir pierre frédéric biguier jouer
mendes secrétaire également de la
section du parti socialiste de bayonne
s'est également avocat merci à tous les
deux d'être là alors on viens de
l'entendre nicolas bay l'eurodéputé
reine qui sera lié un finalement eric
zemmour on peut parler indique revel
d'une nouvelle trahison pour marine le
pen
oui évidemment on veut on peut parler de
trahison il veut parler de transfuges
bon c'est pas d'une grande nouveauté en
fait un don les campagnes électorales on
assiste souvent régulièrement à des
transfuges ce qui passe d'un camp à un
autre bon vous appelez ça les trahisons
moi j'appelle ça les transfuges bon il
faut évidemment mettre en phase les
promesses que l'on fait à ceux qui
quittent à partie pour aller vers un
autre parti mais vous remarqué que quand
nicolas bay qui tu leur as hautmont
nationale pour aller chez eric zemmour
bon il ya l'épaisseur d'une feuille de
cigarette quand même entre les idées et
globalement que portent ces parties même
si nicolas bay dans l'interview du
figaro que vous rappeliez met face à
face comme si elle s'opposait les
notions d'extrémisme et de radicalité
mais à mon sens il ya plus grave dans la
politique française ya les tons sus des
gens qui partent parfois pour un plat de
lentilles un peu plus croustillants et
puis il ya les trahisons des convictions
et pour moi c'est beaucoup plus
important les trahisons
en matière de conviction et là on a
assisté ces dernières années à des
choses absolument incroyable et je vous
expliquerai stéphanie pourquoi mon avis
c'est plus grave de trahir ses
convictions que de passer d'un parti à
un autre en espérant que le soleil
brille un peu plus vous souvenez
peut-être nicolas sarkozy avait fait de
l'ouverture
un marqueur de son quinquennat et
notamment in avait accueilli 7 8 9
transfuge du parti socialiste vous
souvenez peut-être de nous comme ceux de
bernard kouchner qui était socialiste
avec est devenu ministre des affaires
étrangères du nicolas sarkozy président
de droite vous souvenez sans doute
d'eric besson qui lui avait été
secrétaire dé l'économie au parti
socialiste puis qui quelques années plus
tard est devenu secrétaire général
adjoint de l'ump voyez là entrailles et
complètement ses convictions parce du
parti socialiste à gauche à l'ump à
droite et puis il ya un autre cas
illustre il est peut-être moins connue
qu'est jean pierre jouyet jean pierre
jouyet qui a été secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes de françois fillon
est transformé l'homme qui était
socialiste et qui une fois qu'il a
terminé son tour de piste chez l'ump de
l'époque est redevenu secrétaire général
de l'elysée lorsque françois hollande
lui même a été élu président aurait pu
alors on va partout ces trahisons et les
crevettes parce qu'on a je pense qu'on
va faire on va faire quatre heures là si
on revient
simplement vous dire que c'est trahir de
conviction sont plus grave parce que ça
répond la petite musique que finalement
la politique ce n'est pas des
convictions ce sont des places et les
rssi des français se détournent de la
chose politique
il faudrait regarder danser grand
nouveau de perte de conviction
si l'origine de l'abstention si
l'origine de la défiance que les
français ont envers la politique ne
vient pas de ce type de phénomène race
en attente mais mais mais mais mais mais
trahir ses convictions trahir son
essence politique ça me semble beaucoup
plus grave restons en tout cas sur cette
campagne de 2022 et on va évidemment
s'interroger parce que c'est le pendant
sur la raison de la défiance et de
l'abstention il n'empêche marine le pen
subi ces derniers temps des départs
successifs un gilbert collard jérôme
rivière encore stéphane ravier sans
doute peut-être l'une des plus cruelles
pour elle marion maréchal le pen marion
maréchal je crois qu'elle enlevait le
pen dans son nom fin janvier qui confie
que la cohérence la vision la stratégie
la font pencher pour eric zemmour gilles
casanova en essayant de répondre pas
trop longtemps parce qu'on est c'est
vrai qu'on les quatre sur le plateau
s'interroge quand même sur la stratégie
notamment de marine le pen ce qu'elle
doit se remettre en cause eric revel
parler de porosité avec eric zemmour
enfin il ya peut être aussi un
changement de stratégie pour la
président du r'n le coeur du problème
c'est le découplage complet entre la
masse de la population et une toute
petite élite politico médiatique qui
fait qui agit et qui commandent
elle-même à travers le système
médiatique le système politique et comme
elle ne parle que d'elle même elle ne
rencontre pas la population c'est ça le
problème la population elle est sur un
standard droite gauche quand on pose des
questions de fond aux gens ça n'a pas
changé c'est même un peu plus à gauche
qu'avant est ce qu'il faut faire payer
les riches il n'y a jamais eu autant de
gens qui ont répondu oui que en ce
moment et il ya d'autres sujets des
sujets nouveaux par exemple grand
remplacement
61% des français craignent le grand
remplacement autant d'électeurs
mélenchon ou à peu près que des lecteurs
de valérie pécresse donc vous voyez que
dans la société telle qu'elle est pour
90 % de la société on est sur un
référent droite gauche avec des nouveaux
problèmes mais qui se joue dans ce
référent de voix de gauche et puis dans
la petite élite politico médiatique on
est dans un jeu à trois et pas à 2 nous
avons la contestation nous avons
l'identité et nous avons l'argent
l'identité est bien on a des
reclassements sur qui est le meilleur
pour être le représentant du groupe
identitaire dans ce triangle du sommet
et donc c'est les échanges entre la
famille le pen et puis un nouveau venu
qui a un discours quand même qu'ils
répondent un peu plus aux attentes des
gens et qui est un peu moins marquée par
l'histoire le pen nous avons la
contestation avec jean luc mélenchon qui
est le plus représentatif de cette
contestation est donc il attire les gens
qui ne veulent pas filer vers l'argent
ségolène royal par exemple nous avons
l'argent avec au coeur macron et puis
tous ceux qui approchent venant de
droite ou de gauche parce que l'attrait
de l'argent est toujours très fort
pierre frédéric billet on parlera
évidemment du cac dlr parce que pécresse
on le disait a aussi ses petits soucis
en ce moment mais quelle est votre
lecture de ces petites trahisons alors
que eric revel on appellera ça autrement
mais enfin quand même aux airelles elle
l'a vécu comme tel marine le pen s'en
est pas caché c'est la dédiabolisation
qui a pas forcément payé il fallait
rester sur une ligne dure des trahisons
politiques c'est vu comme la politique
c'est à dire que quand on reprend
l'histoire où monsieur revel en parler
c'est vieux comme la politique
maintenant il ya quelques nouveautés
alors on sent bien qu'il ya des
trahisons des ralliements pour
différentes raisons vous avez leur
assemblée nationale les gens partent
parce qu'ils près pas l'après
présidentielle ça on le sent bien ils
veulent recomposer la droite c'est le
tir et le projet de monsieur zemmour
ensuite il ya les trahisons à gauche
aussi on voit que madame royal alors ne
soutient pas mais en tout cas dit que le
vote utile c'est effectivement monsieur
mélenchon ce qui est assez drôle
d'ailleurs parce que monsieur mélenchon
a quitté le parti socialiste en 2008
parce que sa motion est arrivée celle
derrière celle madame royal donc c'est
assez drôle de voir qui allait
retournement comme ça le parti
communiste français s'est fait blouser
par monsieur mélenchon avec qui il avait
fait défiler ses terres accepte donc
c'est vieux comme le monde alors chez
nous chez dr il ya quelques trahisons
aussi quoique ça se tient plutôt pas
trop mal parce que quand on regarde même
chez monsieur jeannot vous avez vu un
jeune homme est tombé tout seul dans son
bateau madame rousseau est rentrée chez
elle sur rigole et c'est donc ça c'est
une vérité maintenant et pas chez vous
alors ayez que chez nous semble-t-il
quand même on a ainsi avoir lu dit les
centristes avec nous les a rassemblés
monsieur woerth est parti guillaume
pelletier partie mais guillaume pottier
quelque part il est revenu à ses
premiers amours voilà il est revenu à
l'extrême droite donc une certaine
logique eric woerth c'est un cas un peu
pas un peu particulier parce que
monsieur eric woerth quand même c'est un
peu se moquer du monde c'est à dire que
quand il dit que monsieur macron n'a pas
cramé la caisse c'est une vaste
fumisterie une vaste plaisanterie
d'ailleurs monsieur macron aussi un
grand de la trahison avec monsieur
hollande même envoyé l'histoire se
répète l'échelle et l'air on est plutôt
et cohérent l'équipe est là et
d'ailleurs valérie pécresse on se tient
quelques ralliements à droite à gauche
mais globalement on par rapport à ce
qu'on voit on n'est pas si malheureux
que ça je m'adresse on parlait bauchet
voilà vous avez aussi vos petits tracas
ségolène royal effectivement petite
petite revanche peut-être voilà qui
aurait dû logiquement soutenir anne
hidalgo vous vous comprenez d'être situe
2 de l'ancienne candidate à la
présidentielle le vote utile mélenchon
vous vous partagez
françois mitterrand dit que sur le
chemin de la trahison n'y a que le
fleuve de la route à traverser ségolène
royal en fait je le regrette comme anne
hidalgo la démonstration c'est vrai que
voilà ségolène royal
je crois à quitter le camp des
socialistes il ya bien longtemps enfin
il ya bien longtemps c'était en 2017 où
il avait appelé à voter pour emmanuel
macron si vous voulez je pense que
ségolène royal n'est plus socialiste
elle fait ses petits arrangements cette
petite tambouille politique un petit
j'en suis totalement conscient il faut
poser la question à ségolène royal qu'il
est voilà qui n'est plus socialiste moi
en tant que militant bien sûr que ça me
choque c'est est la candidate du parti
socialiste qui arrivait au second tour
qui a fait sa carrière grâce au parti
socialiste il faut quand même le dire et
je trouve toujours regrettable bien
voilà de trahir vu que c'est le terme
que j'utiliserai ses convictions ou non
je ne sais peut-être quelques vengeance
ou quelques arrangements personnels
pour revenir
sur cette droite est ce que le problème
aujourd'hui n'est pas cette morosité qui
est de plus en plus flagrant entre voilà
la droite conduit extrême et et la
droite dite républicaine ont tiré plus
qu'à une traditionnelle est
effectivement alors ça ça pouvait
effectivement une des craintes après la
primaire en tout cas le congrès ait
l'air eric zemmour estimé qu'une partie
des militants l ère allait le rejoindre
notamment ceux qui avaient voté pour
eric ciotti ça n'a pas été le cas c'est
flagrant maintenant donc on voit bien
quand même que les vieux partis comme
les nôtres qui ont une histoire sont
ancrées sont assez fidèles à la famille
politique le parti socialiste kaka quand
même un ancrage territorial qui est
quand même assez puissant sur le
territoire français il ya une certaine
cohérence nous en plus y'a les figures
un peu gaullienne sur le parti on voit
bien quand même que ça tient la boutique
et puis a quand même des gens qui sont
de bon niveau xavier bertrand michel
barnier qui rassemble toute la famille
et effectivement je pense que l'échec de
monsieur zemmour là dessus ça a été
notamment le fait de ne pas constater un
départ massif même anecdotique de dlr
vers son parti eric revel votre vision
sur ce que vient de dire à pierre
frédéric billets c'est vrai la famille
dollis traditionnel qui se soude il
n'empêche pays pécresse est en
difficulté en ce moment après cette
séquence du zénith de paris elle est
désormais devancé par eric zemmour dans
plusieurs sondages
votre lecture justement ça suscite
parfois des des trahisons presque
naturel
oui mais il ya une autre en neutralisant
monsieur le maire que l'on ne parlait
pas évidemment ça vous gène peut être un
peu c'est la trahison des idéaux que
portait le rpr des années 90 le rpr des
années 90 il a été il n'était sur la
table des idées et ses idées eric
zemmour a expliqué à tort ou à raison
mais en tout cas une partie de
l'électorat fillonniste le suivi parce
que cet électorat a estimé cette partie
des électorats estimé que ce que vous
disiez lorsque rpr existait dans les
années 90 avec des mots d'ordre très
fort notamment sur l'immigration
l'ump puis les l'air l'ont totalement
boom est donc allé transfuge il ya les
trahisons il ya les aliments mais il ya
aussi des partis politiques qu'ils
renoncent à leurs idées et qui pour une
partie non négligeable de l'électorat
ont trahi leurs idées si vous regardez
les sondages s'apercevrait que valérie
pécresse de cap que 54 % de l'électorat
un fillonniste 10 à 5 ans emmanuel
macron 20% et eric zemmour 18 à 10 9% 6
% seulement pour marine le pen mais ça
veut dire qu'il ya une partie de vos
électeurs qui croyaient au rpr et aux
idées porter le rpr en quatre ans 80
dans les années 90 et qui ne croient
plus à aux idées que porte aujourd'hui à
l'ère don byas transfuge ralliement mais
il ya aussi monsieur le maire trahissons
dans les idées que les parties portait
dont votre jeu mendes ça va pas sonner
le glas cette élection de de tous les
partis traditionnels on voit sa part
chez aimons chez m ont parlé de ségolène
royal qui fait un grand écart c'est la
fin vraiment des parties des gros partis
traditionnels c'est vrai qu'avec
l'élection d' emmanuel macron on peut
convenir qu'il a mis un coup de pied
dans la fourmilière et que ça soit la
droite ou la gauche ont eu du mal à s'en
remettre à se restructurer et
aujourd'hui en bien que c'est le cas en
tant que
républicain attaché aux partis
politiques qui pour moi structure la vie
politique je ne peux que regretter un
petit peu ça a été dit c'est une
tradition des idées notamment de la
droite on pourra dire que chacun balaye
devant sa porte mais sur la droite pour
un parti qui se dit république on vous
l'avait dit à une porosité tout à fait
regrettable entre la droite et l'extrême
droite pour une partie qui se dit
gaulliste on l'a vu au meeting de madame
pécresse sur la question du grand
remplacement on le voit avec eric ciotti
qui représente une ligne et il n'a pas
hésité à le dire sans s'en cacher qu'il
serait prêt en cas de second tour entre
marine le pen
en second tour entre pardon en 30
emmanuel macron eric zemmour a voté pour
eric zemmour donc on voit bien cette
porosité qui gêne en tout cas je pense
que si la gauche a les difficultés elle
est très claire sur ces sujets une
gauche républicaine qui s'assume et
social démocrate mais une gauche en
difficulté aussi sam mendes ça on ne
peut pas le contester une gauche en
difficulté et de manière plus générale
une question qui auxquelles nous devons
répondre c'est qu'est ce qu'être
socialiste au 21ème siècle aujourd'hui
et j'en conviens qu'on a du mal à
répondre à cette question bien qu anne
hidalgo propose un programme clairement
social démocrate mais bien après
l'élection c'est une question à laquelle
il faudra répondre ça je ne le conteste
pas eh bien fatigué vous dites oui la
droite traditionnelle droite dans ses
bottes unis l'autre jour on avait un
invité philippe karsenty qui est
encartée au à l'est républicain soutien
d'eric zemmour
oui vous vous trouvez une forme de
logique tout de même non c'est pas ça je
pense que on pour répondre à monsieur
mendes très rapidement je compte valérie
pécresse a toujours été exemplaire sur
la sur la frontière entre l'extrême
droite et et et notre parti donc là
dessus a pas de débat et de soutien à sa
parole est libre ça c'est pas un sujet
je reviens sur ce qu'a dit monsieur
revel bon il attaque un petit peu sur
revel a comme une grande grande
expérience d'apolitique encore quand on
reprend les programmes des partis
politiques des 80 pour les comparer pour
les comparer aux fins de comparaison
aujourd'hui bon c'est un peu tiré par
les cheveux on pourrait reprendre le
programme pcf et de monsieur mitterrand
2 81-11 irait mais où sont les
convictions et c'est donc monsieur
rebelles et aussi rebelle fait un petit
jeu de passe passe à dessus bon
intellectuellement ce n'est pas tout à
fait honnête je pense monsieur revel ce
n'est pas de votre niveau en tout cas me
semble-t-il donc maintenant à 6,6 7e
honnête j'ai en sommes sûrs de la
girouette c'est d'ailleurs années 90 on
est tous les partis et vous verriez que
les l'évolution programmatique ce qui
est tout à fait logique le fn années 80
était plutôt sur les lignes reagan le
parti socialiste et 80 était pro
prolétariat ce qui n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui et puis nous on a évolué
aussi de faire des comparaisons là
dessus je trouve que c'est un petit peu
si on reprend les déclarations de gaston
defferre ancien maire de marseillan cinq
ministres sur l'immigration ça
choquerait tout le monde aujourd'hui
donc vous voyez bon je pense qu'on peut
faire d archéologie mais c'est un peu
antidaté pour l'attirer voilà gilles
casanova avant justement de parler des
conséquences un petit peu de ces petits
arrangements entre amis qui sont parfois
un petit peu mal perçue par par les
électeurs justement votre vision parce
qu'on parle énormément de cette droite
aujourd'hui qui se cherche un peu qui va
peut-être se réinventer après cette
élection
justement la difficulté qu'il y a c'est
que le parti socialiste comme l air ne
sont pas dans le triangle que j'ai
évoquées contestation identité argent ne
sont pas placés dans ce triangle donc
vous avez une partie de dirigeants du ps
qui n'ont pas du tout comme ségolène
royal rejoint jean luc mélenchon et qui
ont expliqué que la social démocratie
c'était macron c'est à dire le
ralliement au courant central au bloc
élitaire vous avez une partie avec
woerth qui fait la même chose chez
heller et puis vous avez une partie
hachée et l'air comme chez les
socialistes qui va vers la contestation
d'un côté ouvert l'identité de l'autre
c'est à dire que nous avons en absence
d'une cohésion entre la sphère politique
la sphère médiatique et la population un
discours médiatique complètement
extérieure à ce qui se passe avec des
petites discussions sur monsieur machin
va-t-il apporter des voix monsieur truc
va-t-il apporter des voix dont monsieur
machin et monsieur truc vont gagner de
l'argent vallat soyons clairs ils vont
apporter aucune voix à personne parce
que de toute façon vous n'avez plus 15 %
des français qu'ils font confiance à
quelque parti ou quelques personnalités
politiques que ce soit et c'est là le
mou de problème majeur vous avez deux
parties qui ont un grand nombre d'élus
locaux ps et l air et ses deux parties
sont incapables de se placer dans le jeu
politique des élites et ils sont
incapables de répondre aux attentes de
la base sociale des uns et des autres
alors là il ya un double problème très
explosif justement vous avez raison
parce que ses électeurs ils sont parfois
déstabilisés par ces revirements
d'ailleurs je vous propose d'écouter
marine le pen sur ce sujet après la
défection donc de nicolas bay il ne
pouvait plus rester à mes côtés à partir
du moment où les gens se tiennent mal où
ils sont déloyaux ça ne me dérange pas
qu'il parte mais pourquoi rester dans la
campagne le plus longtemps possible pour
saboter de l'intérieur la campagne et
pour finir par faire un cinéma et partir
des comportements comme ça pousse des
gens à arrêter de voter il est même
tonalité
dans ce message télégramme qui vient de
nous parvenir maxime avec tous ces
traîtres comment peut-on se fier aux
candidats comment peut-on avoir envie
d'aller voter un eric revel réfuté le
terme de traitement fin je demandais si
c'est ça le problème parce que vous ça
vous semble peut-être naturel normal on
le voyait avec eric revel qui commentait
la politique depuis quelques années mais
les électeurs eux ça nourrit la défiance
ça nourrit l'abstention à la question
comment décrédibiliser davantage la
parole politique l'engagement politique
je pense que ce petit mercato politique
assez exécrable en est malheureusement
la démonstration j'ai 26 ans j'ai un
engagement politique depuis mes 15 ans
bien sûr je m'intéresse et je milite aux
côtés d'un dialogue mais pour ma
génération les amis avec lesquels je
discute c'est vrai que au delà de ces
petits comportements individuels pour
des postes et bien ça interroge sur la
halle la question de s'intéresser à la
chose publique allez voter c'est vrai
que moi j'essaye de convaincre ici ou là
qu'il faut aller voter même si on
partage pas les mêmes convictions et
aujourd'hui on voit bien que
ces comportements blesse davantage
l'engagement et la parole publique et et
voilà je pense qu'il faut être clair sur
ses opinions
qu'on soit de droite ou de gauche ce qui
permettra je l'espère dans les années à
venir bien de donner un bout
supplémentaire à l'engagement et à la
parole
on vous dit quoi sur le terrain à dreux
les électeurs justement quand on voit
eric woerth qui a toujours critiqué mes
yeux mettront qui le rejoint
soudainement c'est vrai que ça fait pas
forcément bonne impression quand on voit
le nombre d'abstentionnistes alors c'est
tout à fait vrai faux souvenirs quand
même qu'aux législatives et en 2017 on a
eu 50 % de participation nous c'était
historiquement bas on m'a fait une
réflexion ce matin qu'ils étaient très
intéressantes sur les eric woerth on m'a
dit si j'étais bruno le maire je
m'inquiéterais pour mon poste oui
c'était tout à fait intéressant c est
frappée du bon sens oui les gens sont
pas encore dans la campagne électorale
on sent bien il regarde ça de loin sont
pas encore est ce que justement il n'y a
pas ce genre de comportement ne
m'éloigne pas
simplement ça dépasserait perez savait
pas forcément bouger beaucoup de voix on
a besoin que c'est un peu brouillon
système de tambouille politique c'est
assez désagréable
les gens prennent de la distance moi je
me sens bien je dis sous tous les cieux
toujours avec les avec les drouet mama
très belle ville de dreux et les gens se
prennent un petit peu de distance il
faut dire aussi la vérité c'est que
beaucoup de gens attendent que emmanuel
macron descendre dans l'arène voilà ça
c'est un vrai sujet parce que
aujourd'hui on parle entre nous on débat
il ya un espèce de mystère autour d'eux
à quel moment il va se déclarer ça
devient c'est désagréable pour le débat
démocratique
il faut quand même noter on a besoin à
la fois débattre avec le président
sortant parce qu'il va être candidat on
le sait et puis de faire le bilan et de
ce qu'ils proposent par la suite parce
que il faut avoir en tête quand même la
cour des comptes l'a démontré sur la
dette de la france
les enjeux à partir de 2022 2023 vont
être telle qu'on doit avoir un débat
long et démocratique sur le fond qu'est
ce qu'on fait de notre dette la réforme
du système de santé la réforme du
système de la sécurité sociale de l'état
et cetera et cetera et ça c'est pas en
deux trois semaines qu'on va le faire
donc j'espère que vite le débat vint
s'installer qu'on aura les vrais débats
de fond notamment sur les plateaux télé
eric revel justement cette embrouille
politique elles sont pas de nature à
freiner le vrai débat de fond finalement
il ya deux choses qui freine les bonnes
feuilles à ce que vient de dire monsieur
le maire c'est à dire le rapport de la
cour des comptes est très alarmiste sur
niveau de la dette est ce qu'on appelle
la sincérité de la trajectoire
budgétaire pour 2027 vous faites un
cadrage et vous dites en 2027 on sera
dans les clous des critères de
maastricht est en fait la cour des
comptes dit bah il faut 9 à 10 milliards
d'euros d'économies supplémentaires
chaque année si on veut aller dans cette
trajectoire budgétaire ce qui paraît
absolument impossible mais la question
fondamentale c'est qu'avec le niveau de
dette que nous avons aujourd'hui des
2900 milliards d'euros de dette un
déficit public qui a explosé un commerce
extérieur qui est totalement en panne
qui accumule les déficits en fait on
peut se poser une question et les
électeurs vont se la posent et je pense
c'est qu'au delà de toutes les promesses
qui sont faites par tous les candidats
combien sont finançables avec l'état
actuel de la dette
combien de milliards d' euros promise
sur les propositions de candidats vont
rester lettre morte parce qu'elles ne
sont pas finançable vu le niveau de la
dette en france quand vous lisez le
rapport de la cour des comptes et bien
tout ça se traduit dans un indicateur à
mon sens ce qui est l'indicateur de
l'abstention en 81 élection
présidentielle vous avez 80% de
participation en 2017 vous avez 76 75 %
de participation de mémoire et dans le
dernier rolling d'harris interactive on
en l'air on en est à 66 % de
participation donc ça veut dire que en
fait au fur et à mesure des années les
français se déplacent de moins en moins
ils croient peut-être de moins en moins
ou promesses qu'on leur fait ils y ont
cru y croit de moins en moins et quand
vous avez le rapport produit par pierre
moscovici qu'est le premier président de
la cour des comptes ce matin qui dit
barnes est difficilement soutenable ceux
qui vous disent qu'ils vont dépenser
davantage pour vous rendre plus heureux
bah écoutez le mais écoutez là mais ne
croyez pas forcément
leur parler de ce problème de cette
campagne est électorale avec vous et
eric revel et avec nos candidats qui
défileront sur les plateaux merci à tous
les quatre monsieur casanova eric revel
pierre frais des billets et mendes merci
à vous et c'est la fin de cette émission